wir haben hier ja schon öfter mal über
das so genannte fermi paradoxon
berichtet diesem widerspruch zufolge ist
es äußerst seltsam dass die menschen
noch keine außerirdischen entdeckt haben
dabei hätten intelligente zivilisationen
im weltall doch genügend zeit gehabt
weite teile des universums zu
kolonisieren ein forschungsteam hat
jetzt herausgefunden wir wissen einfach
viel zu wenig warum haben wir also noch
keine aliens gefunden jetzt hier bei
pixum science fiction herzlich
willkommen der physiker in rico ferme
hatte 1950 das thema auf den tisch
gebracht und zwar auf einem weg zum
mittagessen als er im gespräch mit
einigen seiner kollegen über
ufo-sichtungen und die existenz von
außerirdischen überhaupt war am ende so
heißt es soll er dann gesagt haben herr
is everybody dass wir trotz intensiver
suche keinerlei spuren von
außerirdischem leben finden sei einfach
nur paradox fand er seitdem wundern sich
forschungsteams weltweit warum wir
einfach keine spuren von außerirdischen
finden denn falls sie existieren müssten
wir dann nicht über hinweise zu ihnen
nur so stolpern
dem ist aber nicht so folgt daraus also
die schlussfolgerung dass es keine
intelligenten außerirdischen gibt dass
sie zb wie zahlreiche zivilisationen
hier vor uns auf der erde und vielleicht
auch wir einfach untergegangen sind sich
zb mit einem selbst verursachten
klimawandel vernichtet haben das unsere
ganze suche nach ihnen von vornherein
erfolglos ist und war dazu gibt es eine
menge erklärungsversuche außerirdische
zivilisationen würden an großen
herausforderungen scheitern das weltall
zu kolonisieren oder aber außerirdische
lebewesen hätten zu viel angst sich uns
zu offenbar wer sagt dann aber dass sie
unbedingt neue galaxien kolonisieren
wollen vielleicht waren sie auch schon
längst bei uns und die beweise dafür
sind zusammen mit den dinosauriern von
der erde verschwunden
und woher sollen die außerirdischen
überhaupt die ressourcen haben um
unzählige andere sterne zu bereisen
ein forschungsteam aus oxford hat sich
diese fragen jetzt gestellt und sich
eingehend mit dem fermi paradoxon
beschäftigt in ihrer arbeit
argumentieren sie dass alle unsere an
haben zur existenz von außerirdischen
extrem unsicher sind und wenn man diesen
wissens mangel berücksichtigt dann sei
unsere erfolglose suche nach ihnen gar
nicht mehr so paradox wie von fermi
beschrieben gar nicht so
unwahrscheinlich sei demnach auch dass
die menschen tatsächlich die einzige
intelligente zivilisationen im universum
sein
ihre annahme stützt das oxford
forschungsteam auf der so genannten
drake gleichung dabei ging diese
kurioserweise in vielen anderen
argumentation als beleg dafür dass es
viele andere zivilisationen in unserem
universum geben muss aufgestellt wurde
sie tatsächlich um zu berechnen wie viel
intelligente zivilisationen im universum
existieren könnten konkret enthält die
drake gleichung viele verschiedene
faktoren in diesem kontext
beispielsweise die anzahl der planeten
in der habitablen zone und die chance
dass dort leben entsteht so wie auch die
wahrscheinlichkeit wie intelligentes
dann sein könnte
doch ihr könnt es euch denken die
meisten der dort befragten faktoren
basieren lediglich auf groben
schätzungen da konkrete zahlen fehlen
und so werden schätzwerte eingesetzt so
dass die drake gleichung sehr sehr
unterschiedliche ergebnisse liefert wie
kommen die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler also auf ihr ergebnis
das forschungsteam nimmt keine
schätzwerte in ihrer studie sondern
wahrscheinlichkeit verteilung die auf
zahlen basieren die wissenschaftliche
literatur verwendet werden und das
ergebnis ist eindeutig demnach sind wir
mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 53 bis
achtung 99,6 in unserer milchstraße
allein und im sichtbaren universum liegt
die wahrscheinlichkeit dafür bei 39 85
prozent doch die studien autorinnen und
autoren machen einschränkungen
beispielsweise würde die entdeckung von
leben auf einem anderen planeten die
wahrscheinlichkeit erhöhen dass sich
auch anderweitig noch leben entwickeln
kann also zum beispiel auf enceladus
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher an
dass am berg in einem interview mit
futurezone.at aber selbst dann gibt es
durch die unsicherheit für die
entstehung von komplexem leben und
intelligenz immer noch eine gute chance
dass wir die einzige zivilisation in
einem belebten universum sind wenn das
leben das wir anderswo finden genau wie
das leben auf der erde ist und nur durch
meteoriten
den himmelskörpern transportiert wurde
sagt uns das gar nichts der forscher ist
zudem der überzeugung dass eine
kontaktaufnahme zu außerirdischer
intelligenz auf gar keinen fall
unmöglich ist dafür müsste man seiner
meinung nach zielgerichtet nach signalen
suchen die außerirdisches leben
unabsichtlich verschickt durch
industrielle aktivitäten beispielsweise
oder durch das errichten großer bauwerke
das forschungsteam aus oxford nimmt
allerdings an dass das prinzip von der
entstehung von leben alles andere als
einfach ist falls sie es irgendwann
einmal widerlegt werden könnte müsste
man von limitierenden faktoren ausgehen
die unsere kommunikation mit
außerirdischem leben so schwer
beziehungsweise unmöglich machen
beispielsweise weil die anderen
zivilisationen in wasser gefangen sind
und so praktisch stumm bleiben
das fazit der aktuellen studie der
wissensstand der menschheit ist so klein
dass es gar nicht überraschend ist das
werk ein außerirdisches leben sehen doch
versteht mich nicht falsch das
forschungsteam aus oxford meint damit
auf gar keinen fall dass wir zu 100
prozent allein im universum sind dazu
noch einmal sandberg wir wissen
schlichtweg nicht genug um so etwas zu
behaupten leben und intelligenz könnten
überaus selten seien das einzige was wir
sicher sagen können dass beides möglich
ist die unsicherheit zeigt uns dass
selbst wenn leben und die intelligenz
folglich sind zivilisationen trotzdem so
selten sein können dass der leere himmel
nicht überraschend ist der forscher
selbst ist übrigens der persönlichen
überzeugung dass es andere intelligente
lebensformen im all gibt wenn er kein
video verpassen wollt auch extra videos
und livestreams nicht dann werdet
mitglieder auf dem kanal und nimmt auch
noch ein paar privilegien mit außerdem
unterstützt sie uns mit einem kleinen
beitrag einfach auf mitglied werden hier
unter diesem video klicken und danke an
alle die schon dabei sind das macht uns
etwas unabhängiger von den schwankenden
werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube
wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle
videos informiert werden wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht der
die etwas unzuverlässige abbog sie auf
youtube und ihr verpasst kein video
einfach hier draufklicken und am besten
auch mein schwesterkanal kriegst um
social media abonnieren
dafür hier klicken aber natürlich nicht
achtung die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
außerirdische revolution bei der suche
bis dann bleibt dran